the the me uh of the the new um
ecodesign uh review uh we will have some
questions for you alisander today so we
can uh understand a bit more of this
revision um and maybe we can start with
your own words uh you said uh we still
live in a take make uh dispose culture
and in in your in your opinion how is
this new revision of the European
Union's uh ecodesign framework for
sustainable products going to change
this mindset what are in your opinion
the main or the most important changes
that this revision brings thank you
kerina to invite me to have an exchange
of views about this important regulation
that as you said before will have a a
very strong impact uh on our society our
business and our consumer
H the regulation will in fact radically
change the way in which industry
operates showing the way to manage the
entire life cycle of a product
production including the end of life and
believe me it will change uh for a
better and this regulation Finds Its
rational in respect affecting the limit
of our planet establishing a legislative
framework that will contribute to making
products compant with a climate neutral
resource efficient and circular economy
the products that will be progressively
placed on the European market therefore
we have to be designed in such a way uh
as to respect the environment the
ecosystem and protect the health of
consumers furthermore it will allow
consumers to save energy to enable them
to repair the products they buy rather
than having to throw them away and to
give them the opportunity through the
digital passport to be fully aware of
what they buy and to choose for quality
and respect the
environmental some of the most important
changes that this revision will
bring are in my opinion this the first
one is the introduction of a direct
ban uh for the destruction of unsold
textiles and Footwear the second is is
the introduction of strong provision
which will restrict the um um the
presence of substances of concern into
the products making it easier to dispose
them at the end of their life and the
third is the digital product
passport okay we will get to some of
them uh throughout the questions um you
said something very important there
regarding the the the life cycle and uh
being able to repair as someone who has
been very frustrated by having a fully
functional computer that became
worthless uh because there were no
longer updates for the computers so I
could install and support the whole
operating system uh I was very happy to
see that in this report uh the European
Union is is now trying to guarantee that
companies make available not only
consumables and spare parts and
accessories but also um functioning
software um so software updates for an
appropriate period of time my question
is how do you assess uh what is an
appropriate period um and for how many
years are we going to have to guarantee
uh responsibility or companies going to
have to guarantee uh repairability in
the European
Union indeed this is a very important
provision of the regulation but please
don't forget that this regulation just
lie down a framework for setting
ecodesign requirements such as uh
product durability
reusability H upgradability and
reparability so however it does remain a
framework the content of which will be
further defined by the commission
through delegated acts this is the
reason why I think that functioning
software updates should work for an
appropriate period which should be
evaluated by the appropriated actors
meaning the European commission taking
into account the specific
characteristics of each product group
okay so different timings for different
uh product groups right thank you uh
still on the software updates uh how is
the European Union guaranteeing that
these updates are not just pretend for
example I think we have all experienced
uh the pain of installing a new uh phone
update on a phone that works and then
the phone becoming painfully slow the
update is available but in practice uh
it is still programs of
solance uh in this
this is the reason why in the regulation
we stressed that echos design
requirements should also address
practices associated with premature
obsolet such practices have in fact an
overall negative impact on the
environment in the form of increased
waste and use of energy and materials we
also managed to introduce a definition
of what premature OBS silence Theos
design however should also be read in
close connection with the recently
adopted empowering consumer directive
which among other things aims uh to
better protect consumers against unfair
practices such as early OBS and product
with a commercial guarantee will have a
label indicating its length and a
reminder of obligatory legal guarantee
in that way
consumers um will be able to identify
which products will last longer than
others okay thank you that's a very
important revision um I believe one of
the most uh ambitious ambitious and
important uh proposals of this report is
one that you CED earlier today uh which
is the ban on the destruction uh of
unsold textiles and Footwear um however
another aspect uh of the rules uh of
this report is the need to make clothing
repairable uh which will require
manufacturers uh to produce spare parts
for example zippers and shoelaces so
that people can repair their clothing
and their shoes so my question is how
can we ensure that manufacturers produce
enough products uh and spare parts for
consumers to be able to repair and
maintain their clothing uh and Footwear
while also not producing so many that
they have to go to waste because they
cannot destroy them
anymore the ban of the destruction of
unsold textiles and food wear is a very
important aspect of this regulation
which wasn't present in the original
commission proposal and a point which is
very close to my heart the destruction
of textiles and foodware is in fact
becoming a widespread environmental
problem throughout the Union in
particular due to the rapid growth of
online sales this amounts to a loss of
economic resources as goods are produced
transported and subsequently destroyed
without even being used for their indeed
propose this regulation therefore
represent a turning point the
introduction of a direct ban of unsold
excd and Footwear will contribute to a
paradigma shift in the way in which
especially h some large companies
produce their goods the direct ban will
enter into Force two years after the
entry uh into force of the regulation
small and micro companies will be
Exempted of this ban while medium siiz
companies will benefit of a six years
exemption according to an
ongoing uh stud clothing and Footwear
waste waste amounted to
5.2 Mega ton equivalent to 12 kilos per
person per year in the European Union in
the light of these numbers the issue of
the availability of spare parts is in my
opinion an
nonissue our main objective should be
contrast the phenomena of fast fashion
and given the number we are taking about
I don't foresee any possible shortage of
H spare parts okay got it thank you so
much um just to uh close this topic um
on the destruction of unsold items do
you think companies will argue that this
may disrupt their economies of scale and
leads to increasing product
prices as I said before the regulation
will call for a paradig shift in the way
in which in particular some big
companies should produce their goods the
regulation will provide consumers which
access to better information and higher
quality products the cost of
manufacturing the products that will be
um
regulated are expected to increase with
possibility that some may be being pest
on the consumers The Experience under
the current ecodesign directive however
is that increased manufacturing costs
are more than offset by Financial
savings for consumers over the long term
improved product performance
and longer functionability will reduce
the need to replace products and lead to
overall cost saving including through uh
lower energy and resour consumption
better performance durability
upgradability and reparability as well
as higher value at the end of life thank
you it's very important to to do the
whole math right regarding the whole
experience and lifespan of the product
um yes in in this report in the
ecodesign report um something very
interesting that is proposed and you
talked about it earlier uh is the
creation of a product passport which
should contain the products
environmental and social impact how will
this work in real life how what kind of
information should it be there the
digital passport represents in my
opinion an important in inovation in the
current Panorama and um the size tool
for promoting circularity the new pro
products uh that will be available on
the market can in fact be sold only if
accompanied by this tool which must
contain accurate and updated information
on the environmental impact of the
products in circulation the passport
will help consumers and also business to
make informed choices when purchasing
products and help public authorities to
better perform checks and
controls H how it will work in practice
every product that will be sold will be
accompanied by a QR code or with other
similar tools through which the
consumers will
be H Consciousness um and redirected to
a page where they will find precise and
update information on the environmental
impact of products in circulation which
will allow them to make informed choices
facilitate repairs and Recycling and
increase transparency on the environment
impact of what what they want to to
choose and to buy so in this regard I
also hope that one day not too far away
the product passport will also be used
at least for some product categories as
a tool to provide information also on
the social sustainability of the product
which unfortunately is not the case
today um could you please elaborate on
um the importance of giving consumers
information not only about the
environmental sustainability but but
also their social impacts in particular
in the textile SE sector why is this
important the scope of the commission
proposal only covers the environmental
sustainability of the product I do
however think that it was a missed
opportunity to have not been able extend
it also to the social one I tried hard
during the negotiation but unfortunately
I found a strong opposition both from
the center right wing parties of the
European Parliament and also from the
council uh we all know that in the
textile sector there is a serious social
ISS issue some Brands often don't pay
aescent wage to the actors in the
production chain and don't always
redistribute the wealth generate
equality H so we must therefore act and
intervene to remove the relevance of
fast fashion as a model based on the
over production of low quality clothes
and no longer legitimize induced of over
consumption the EU should force
manufacturers and large fashion
companies to operate more
sustainability
disasters occurred in the past such as
the collapse of theana Plaza Factory in
Bangladesh 10 years ago H the increasing
textile land fields in Ghana and Nepal
polluted water and the the Pres of
microplastics in our oceans show what
happens if we don't not pursue this goal
these recurring disasters are wake up
call the Western world including the you
to take the responsibility for the
consequences of placing consumers
preferences over ABD and accessibility
at the expense of moderation and
sustainability way to use uh Goods the
intent is therefore to ensure that
companies convert their production
towards quality fashion accessible to
all as I ever as I already said in
Europe alone each of us discard around
20 kilos of clothes every year
and must of this waste increases the
pollution of ecosystems around the world
but without hypocrisy we must say that
it mainly pollutes the poorest countries
which have become the repressible of
what we are
discarding just think about Ghana
Bangladesh of Chile over production and
over consumption are causing immense
damage to to our planet often in the
general
indifference in this context the
devastating role of face fastp is clear
for all to see encouraging people to buy
through away and byy again again in the
endless Circle in this sense H it
therefore becomes fundamental to provide
consumers with information on social
experts and educate them on more
responsible consumption through a do
awareness campaigns unfortunately for
the moment on social issues we have only
managed to insert into the text only a
review uh close According to which
within F four years of entry into Force
the regulation the commission will be
called upon to consider the inclusion of
social sustainability in its scope of
application okay let's hope in the
future we can see I hope so I hope so
but we have to to work very hard yes
true uh it's it's the kind of work that
needs to be done so thank you so much I
have just one uh final question um that
is when can we expect to see all these
measures uh taking effect in the
European Union
the regulation will be voted in plenary
either in March or in April and it will
end to uh enter into force uh 20 days
after its publication in the official uh
Journal H meaning that at the latest
miday H but the regulation provides also
some specific deadlines for example the
ban on the distraction of unsold Goods s
will now enter into Force two years
after the entry into force of the
regulation the delegated act which will
adopted by the commission under the
regulation will on the other hand enter
into Force 80 18 months after their
adoption in order to give the
manufacturers and member State national
authorities the time to adapt to the new
the echo design
requirements thank you so much Alexander
for explaining everything so clearly and
also for your amazing work in this Echo
design revision thank you so much thank
you Karina and thank you so much for
your support thank
you